y eso es solo una página web.
Un patrón similar se observa una y otra vez
cuando videos de decapitaciones fueron lanzados durante la Guerra de Irak.
Las redes sociales han hecho que estas imágenes sean más accesibles que nunca,
pero si damos un paso atrás en la historia,
veremos que fue la cámara la que primero creó un nuevo tipo de público
en nuestra historia de decapitaciones como espectáculo público.
Tan pronto como la cámara apareció en la escena,
toda una vida atrás, el 17 de junio de 1939,
tuvo un efecto inmediato e inequívoco.
Ese día, la primera película de una decapitación pública se filmó en Francia.
Fue la ejecución, el guillotinado, de un asesino en serie alemán, Eugen Weidmann,
fuera de la prisión de Saint-Pierre, en Versalles.
Weidmann iba a ser ejecutado al amanecer,
como era costumbre en la época,
pero su verdugo era nuevo en el trabajo,
y había subestimado cuánto tiempo le tomaría para prepararse.
Así Weidmann fue ejecutado a las 4:30 de la mañana,
momento en el cual en una mañana de junio,
había suficiente luz para tomar fotografías,
y un espectador en la multitud filmó el evento,
sin el conocimiento de las autoridades.
Se tomaron varias fotografías también
y todavía se puede ver la película en línea hoy
y mirar las fotografías.
La multitud en el día de la ejecución de Weidmann
fue denominada "rebelde" y "desagradable" por la prensa,
pero eso no era nada en comparación con los miles y miles de personas
que ahora podrían estudiar la acción
una y otra vez,
congelar cada detalle.
La cámara puede haber hecho estas escenas más accesible que nunca jamás,
pero no se trata solo de la cámara.
Si damos un gran salto hacia atrás en la historia,
veremos que durante el tiempo que ha habido
ejecuciones judiciales públicas y decapitaciones,
ha habido una multitud para verlas.
En Londres, en fecha tan tardía como el siglo XIX,
podía haber 4 o 5 mil personas viendo un ahorcamiento estándar.
Podría haber 40 000 o 50 000 viendo matar a un famoso criminal.
Y una decapitación, que era un evento raro en Inglaterra en el momento,
atraía aún más.
En mayo de 1820,
5 hombres conocidos como Conspiradores de la Calle Cato
fueron ejecutados en Londres por planear
asesinar a miembros del gobierno británico.
Fueron colgados y luego decapitados.
Era una escena horripilante.
La cabeza de cada hombre fue cortada y levantada a la multitud.
Y 100 000 personas,
eso es 10 000 más que la que pueden caber en el estadio de Wembley,
había resuelto ir a verlo.
Las calles estaban llenas.
La gente había alquilado ventanas y tejados.
La gente había subido a carros y carretas en la calle.
La gente se subió a los postes de luz.
Había gente muerta en la aglomeración en los días de ejecuciones públicas.
La evidencia sugiere que a lo largo de nuestra historia
de decapitaciones y ejecuciones públicas,
la gran mayoría de las personas que iban a verlas
eran o entusiastas o, como mucho, impasibles.
La repugnancia ha sido relativamente rara,
e incluso cuando la gente que está disgustada y se horroriza,
no siempre deja de salir de todos modos de ver.
Tal vez el ejemplo más llamativo
de la capacidad humana de ver una decapitación y permanecer impasible
e incluso estar decepcionado
fue la introducción en Francia en 1792 de la guillotina,
la famosa máquina de decapitación.
Para nosotros en el siglo XXI,
la guillotina puede parecer como un artilugio monstruoso,
pero para las primeras multitudes que la vieron, en realidad fue una decepción.
Estaban acostumbrados a una larga, interminable, ejecución tortuosa,
donde las personas eran mutiladas y quemadas y se separaban lentamente.
Para ellos, ver la guillotina en acción,
era tan rápida, que no había nada que ver.
La hoja cayó, la cabeza cayó en una cesta en seguida fuera de la vista
y gritaron,
"Devuélveme mis horca, devuélveme mis horca de madera".
El fin de las ejecuciones judiciales públicas de tortura en Europa y EE. UU.
era en parte de ser más humanos hacia el criminal,
pero también fue en parte porque la gente se negó obstinadamente a comportarse
de la manera que deberían.
Con demasiada frecuencia, el día de la ejecución
era más como un carnaval que como una ceremonia solemne.
Hoy, una ejecución judicial pública en Europa o EE. UU. es impensable,
pero hay otros escenarios que deberían hacernos cautos
al pensar que las cosas son diferentes hoy
y que no nos comportamos de esa manera más.
Tomemos, por ejemplo, los incidentes de hostigamiento del suicidio.
Esto es cuando una multitud se reúne
para ver una persona que ha subido a la cima de un edificio público
con el fin de quitarse la vida,
y la multitud grita y se burla,
"¡Hazlo! ¡Salta!"
Este es un fenómeno bien conocido.
Un periódico en 1981 encontró que en 10 de 21 amenazas de intento de suicidio,
hubo incidentes de incitación al suicidio y burlones en la multitud.
Y ha habido incidentes reportados en la prensa de este año.
Este fue un incidente muy ampliamente reportado
en Telford y Shropshire en marzo de este año.
Y cuando sucede hoy en día,
las personas toman fotografías y se toman vídeos en sus teléfonos
y publican los videos en línea.
Cuando se trata de asesinos brutales que publican sus videos decapitación,
Internet ha creado un nuevo tipo de público.
Hoy en día, la acción tiene lugar en un tiempo y lugar lejanos,
lo que da al espectador sensación de desapego de lo que está pasando,
un sentido de separación.
No tiene nada que ver conmigo.
Ya ha pasado.
También nos ofrece un sentido sin precedentes de la intimidad.
Hoy en día, estamos en primera fila.
Todos podemos ver en privado, en nuestro propio tiempo y espacio,
y nadie necesita saber nunca que hemos hecho clic en la pantalla para ver.
Este sentido de la separación
--de otras personas, del evento en sí--
parece ser clave para entender nuestra capacidad de ver,
y hay varias maneras
en las que Internet crea un sentido de desprendimiento
que parece erosionar la responsabilidad moral individual.
Nuestras actividades en línea a menudo se contraponen con la vida real,
como si las cosas que hacemos en línea fueran de alguna manera menos reales.
Nos sentimos menos responsables de nuestras acciones
cuando interactuamos en línea.
Hay una sensación de anonimato, un sentido de la invisibilidad,
nos sentimos menos responsables de nuestro comportamiento.
Internet también hace que sea mucho más fácil toparse con cosas sin darse cuenta,
cosas que solemos evitar en la vida cotidiana.
Hoy, un vídeo puede empezar a mostrarse incluso antes de saber qué estás viendo.
O uno puede tener la tentación de ver material que no miraría en la vida normal
o uno no miraría si estuviera con otras personas en el momento.
Y cuando la acción es pregrabada
y tiene lugar en un tiempo y espacio lejanos
verla parece una actividad pasiva.
No hay nada que pueda hacer ahora.
Ya ha pasado.
Todas estas cosas hacen que sea más fácil como usuarios de Internet
que demos sentido a nuestra curiosidad acerca de la muerte,
y empujar nuestros límites personales,
para probar nuestro sentido de shock, para explorar nuestro sentido de shock.
Pero no somos pasivos cuando miramos.
Por el contrario, estamos cumpliendo el deseo del asesino de ser visto.
Cuando la víctima de una decapitación está atada e indefensa,
él o ella se convierte en un peón en el espectáculo de su asesino.
A diferencia de una cabeza de trofeo que se toma en batalla,
que representa la suerte y habilidad que se necesita para ganar una pelea,
cuando se pone en escena una decapitación,
cuando es esencialmente una pieza de teatro,
el poder viene de la recepción que el asesino recibe cuando la realiza.
En otras palabras, la observación es una parte muy importante del evento.
El evento ya no tiene lugar en una única ubicación
en un cierto punto en el tiempo como antes y como todavía puede parecer.
Ahora el evento está extendido en tiempo y lugar,
y todo el que mira juega su parte.
Debemos dejar de ver,
pero sabemos que no lo haremos.
La historia nos dice que no lo haremos,
y los asesinos lo saben también.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Gracias. Démosles espacio. Gracias.
Vamos aquí. Mientras instalan para la próxima actuación,
Quiero hacerte la pregunta que probablemente muchos tienen,
que es, ¿cómo llegaste a interesarte en este tema?
Frances Larson: Trabajaba en un museo
llamado el Museo Pitt Rivers en Oxford,
que era famoso por su exhibición de cabezas reducidas de América del Sur.
La gente decía: "¡Oh, el museo de cabezas reducidas, el museo cabezas reducidas!"
Y en ese momento, yo estaba trabajando en la historia
de las colecciones científicas de cráneos.
Estaba trabajando en las colecciones craneales,
y solo me pareció irónico
que aquí había gente que iba a ver esta sangrienta, primitiva, cultura salvaje
que estaban casi fantaseando sobre esto e inventando
sin comprender realmente lo que estaban viendo,
y todo el tiempo estas vastas --me refiero a cientos de miles
de cráneos en nuestros museos, en todo Europa y EE. UU.--
fueron un tipo de defensa de esta búsqueda
de la Ilustración de la racionalidad científica.
Así que quise darle la vuelta y decir: "Vamos a ver con nosotros".
Miramos a través de un cristal estas cabezas reducidas.
Miremos nuestra historia y nuestra propia fascinación cultural con estas cosas.
BG: Gracias por compartir esto.
FL: Gracias.
(Aplausos)